all right so the next figure is holding
lee and he's going to talk about
generalizing close
hi i'm olden me from duke and today i'll
talk about
some work i did on degenerative models
trying to understand them from a
theoretical perspective
uh and we'll see some nice bits of
interesting maps along the way and this
is joint work with shiraz aneesh and
andre from cmu
okay so deep generative models
so as we've seen in recent years
deep learning has
made impressive progress and allowed us
to generate photorealistic images and
videos
um with really impressive results
so for example uh here
one of these faces is real and the other
one is generated from a deep neural
network
so i'll give you a few seconds to try
and
guess which one is
okay so it turns out the one on the bus
is real the one on the right side
okay so let's take a step back and look
at the setup
so the goal is that
for given samples from some distribution
p
for example
distribution of
images of faces we want to learn a
distribution that's close to p
and we want to do so in a way such that
we can efficiently sample from that
distribution
and the approach in modern deep learning
is to fit a distribution pg that's
parameterized by a neural network g
so here we start with some tractable
distribution
like a gaussian
and we send that to our newer network
and we want the resulting output we want
that distribution to be the distribution
that we want to approximate
so this will take a question into some
very complicated distribution
okay so i'll describe two approaches uh
to this problem so one is scans or
generative adversarial networks
recently another type of approach has
gained a lot of popularity it's called
normalizing flows
and it aims to resolve some of the
shortcomings of gans
in particular one key advantage is that
it allows sufficient computation of the
likelihood to find the probability of
any particular data
however basic representational questions
about normalizing flows are still not
well understood
and that's the focus of our work
okay so first to set up what gans are so
gans are based on this game's theoretic
idea we have a generator who is
attempting to
imitate this natural distribution
so let's give it an adversary called the
discriminator who tries to distinguish
between the generated images and the
real images
and then this turns it into this min max
problem
okay so gans have enjoyed uh tremendous
success in creating photorealistic
images even with relatively small models
and they do allow efficient sampling
however they have some drawbacks
uh first training could be unstable
because it's this mid max problem it's
typically less stable than a pure
optimization problem
another problem is evaluation
we don't get access to a likelihood so
it's actually hard to evaluate how well
it fits the real distribution
so i'll introduce another approach
called normalizing flows
the idea here is to parametrize the
generator g to be invertible
this is a key restriction that allows
efficient computation of the likelihood
and this is because we can calculate by
the change of variables formula but
excessive formula for the probability
density
of any particular point
so we can see that's in terms of the
determinant of the jacobian of this map
and this means we can calculate the log
likelihood and then we can optimize it
by gradient ascent
however in this form it's still not
efficient enough
because calculating this determinant can
take a decubed time
so there's one more key ingredient here
to make it efficient
this brings us to the idea of affine
coupling normalizing flows
the idea is to restrict the form of g to
allow efficiently that is linear time
computable brilliance
and
this is
one of the
most successful methods in terms of
allowing normalizing flows to scale to
high resolution images
so skipping over some of the details
the idea is that we want to parametrize
the layers
of this neural network so that the
resulting jacobian is going to be
triangular
and this means that we can
calculate the
determinant simply as the product along
the diagonal
for the details this is an affine
coupling normalizing flow
half of the coordinates are copied at
each step and for the other half it's a
alkaline transformation given the
remaining coordinates
okay so flow models
can
resolve some of the drawbacks
that gans have in particular they allow
stabler training since we have the
likelihood objective that we're
maximizing
and it's also easier to evaluate
since we do have the likelihood function
harvard introduces some new issues
in particular needs to be larger
than the dam needs to be in order to
get the same performance uh and a major
problem is that
it can turn out to be ill-conditioned
during training uh jacobian could become
close to singular and
uh making the objective blow up
uh so
this point is what i'll focus on here
question is is this an inherent
difficulty or
something we could overcome
okay so a natural question is these two
is the question of which
which distributions can be represented
by well-conditioned affine coupling
normalizing flows
and i'll get this adjective from there
on and just call it normalization
so a series of recent works have uh
established universal approximation
uh particular colorado for uh alkaline
problem networks
however all these constructions are
poorly conditioned
so as the required accuracy epsilon goes
to zero the jacobian actually becomes
singular and this happens no matter how
nice the underlying distribution is
so our goal is to try and overcome this
and we show that in fact we have
universal approximation with uh
well-conditioned normalizing flows for a
large class of distributions by naming
logical distributions
so roughly our main theorem says that a
lot concave distribution with
conditional capital can be approximated
with a normalizing flow
uh with condition number that's
polynomial and capital
and for the details lot of concrete
distribution this is the hessian of the
log pdf is
a or the negative of this is a convex
function with condition numbers
so we actually consider a padded version
with iv gaussian variables
and
and by approximation here we mean that
for any approximation accuracy epsilon
we can get within epsilon in losses
distance
and as
the key point to note here is that
there's no dependence of the condition
number on the
accuracy epsilon
okay and uh it's also noted that
gaussian pattern has been empirically
noted to improve the condition
okay just a few words about the proof uh
two ingredients one is underdamped
longivian dynamics
sd used for sampling from the gibbs
distribution
and this produces a flow between the
target distribution and the standard
gaussian with good condition
and a second we showed that these
dynamics can be simulated by sequence of
what's called hanal like maps
actually a general generalization of
this
and then discretizing this dynamical
system then gives an alpha and conflict
so these are
kind of connected to synthetic different
life
okay so there's a lot of open questions
here so primary west can we relax the
assumption of law concavity it'd be nice
so we looked at the question of
representability but what i'd really
like to understand is optimization does
gradient descent find a good solution
and finally i would like to compare to
other generative models or the
separations between the different models
uh can make normalizing flows more
competitive and efficient
okay so that's it here's some of my
other work and feel free to talk to me
[Applause]
this is um new to me so i'm not sure if
this question will make any sense or not
but um so you know it is it is it
possible that you know maybe one
interpretation of this is you're trying
to find a good choice of obstacles
you're a good choice of transport mass
from for example a gaussian to your
desired target measure that has some you
know nice properties like most
polynomials
or things like that
and an obstacle is that the determinant
uh
could be
deteriorating um maybe along the
training dynamics and so i guess uh
one thing i was wondering is um you know
i know a lot full transport type of
things
is there any kind of appropriate analog
of that in this context
um
so i guess this in this this case is
okay so i think that's a really
interesting question if you're trying to
explore connections around that transfer
so this is a deterministic map from
you know telstra data
i guess
so
this is something contrasting with your
stochastic
stochastic map where you allow
randomness
um
and
i think
uh the deterministic natures are what
allows the easy complication of
likelihood